[Musique]
allez allez
ils étaient nombreux à avoir accepté
l'invitation de la 11e promotion de l'
académie des dalons à la plaine des
cafres partenaires associatifs
intervenants tous ont participé à ce jeu
de l'oie grandeur nature sur le thème de
l'homophobie
donc il ya des jeux de sportifs jeux
réflexion je dresse des épreuves de
groupe pour faire valoir la cohésion une
réflexion sur les discriminations et les
jugements changer son regard sur
l'homosexualité c'est le projet porté
par cette promotion de jeunes femmes on
est plus tolérant par rapport à ça
d'accord c'est adapté maintenant
maintenant d abord des préjugés mais
maintenant on va commenter ça on juge
plus et maintenant comprendre comment
ils se sentent dans leur peau donc ben
non séparés poids nous donc c'est des
gens comme nous tout simplement
elles sont douze d'allonnes âgés entre
18 et 25 ans a intégré cette 11ème
promotion de l'académie en difficulté
sociale et en recherche d'insertion
professionnelle saidal on retrouve ici
un accompagnement et un suivi afin
qu'elle puisse reprendre confiance en
elles donc elles font un cursus de 12
mois donc trois mois en internat dans le
cas des trois mois on va remobiliser
leurs compétences d'un stick et leurs
difficultés leur permet de prendre
confiance en soi et se dépasser
puis après donc nettement où elles vont
partir en mission de service civique où
on va transposer effectivement les
compétences qu'elles ont acquis dans le
cadre de l'internât sur l'externat pour
amener vers un projet par la suite
d'insertion professionnelle c'est un
très bel outil
une session que ces jeunes qui passent
par cette passat academy basse au delà
en russie
et un peu plus sûrs d'eux puisque
justement le but c'est de kiss kiss et
pour ceux qui ont perdu un peu confiance
dans la société varrault prennent
justement et seront puisse aussi se
remettre en question à travers les
ateliers et l'équipe qui les
accompagnent en quatre années de
fonctionnement l' académie des dalons de
la plaine des cafres dresse un bilan
positif de ses actions auprès des jeunes
65% des dalons après leur passage à
l'académie réussissent leur insertion en
milieu professionnel
[Musique]